I've waited 30 years for that I still
remember my last orders
day the real war began
[Music]
there is that you cannot be allowed to
proceed
when exacting special forces that's the
point sergeant impossible tawanda to
them we offend our Emperor
yeah
that is the question
so cannot change
you
[Music]
hey youtubers is Charlie playable kylo
Ren playable Luke Skywalker let's break
this down if you're new to the channel I
do Star Wars every week so be sure to
subscribe to get everything and I
probably do a giveaway for the game when
it gets closer to coming out but it's
not coming out till November 17th they
do have pre-orders available now
the special edition gives you this extra
content I'll let you pause the video if
you want here but it's the pretty
standard deal just like a little bit
extra more skins more characters more
toys to start out with but the
characters is featured in the trailer it
seems like the main character she's one
of the main characters but I'll explain
how you can actually play as kylo Ren
and Luke Skywalker in the campaign mode
so even though one of the big stories is
centered on her you can play as other
characters but she's called iDEN burr so
she is the leader of this special squad
called Inferno squad she was raised like
Finn in a lot of the other force awakens
stormtroopers in complete isolation in
its Imperial utopia where they just got
them to believe every last drop of
Imperial doctrine so she has hardcore
empire flag waver in a story as you can
see picks up after the destruction of
the second Death Star in the Battle of
Endor the story will cover the rise of
the first-order as the Empire descends
into chaos but the story is supposed to
cover that giant thirty year period
between Episode six and Episode seven
it'll also incorporate a lot of the
expanded universe they've started
rewriting now so operation cinder is a
big event in the game if you don't know
what that is it takes place right after
the Battle of Endor it's one of emperor
palpatine contingency plans and it was
part of the journey to the force awakens
so remember how they wrote a couple
books that explained a little bit about
what happened between the trilogy's this
was one of those stories so it just
involves the scouring of Naboo and a
bunch of other planets so what a
coincidence that the character I Denver
CO is the leader of something called
Inferno squad so this is what she means
when she says she's waited 30 years for
this and they show the first order base
so this is covering all that time and if
you're wondering who this red character
is if you didn't read the shattered
Empire story this mysterious hologram of
Emperor Palpatine appears and tells
these imperial officers you've been
selected for a very special task and
that's what leads into operation cinder
so it's not necessarily the force spear
of Palpatine is just part of his
contingency plan he has multiple ways of
living on beyond his death they go way
beyond technology so this was more of a
technology solution to that as opposed
to the dark empire solution where he
just transferred his spirit into a clone
of himself
so obviously this being a game a couple
years after the last battlefront game
came out the graphics the gameplay look
a little bit better a little bit tweaked
I think they tried to fix a lot of the
multiplayer experience but the
multiplayer battles are what they're
also hyping up here where you see Yoda
fighting Darth Maul in because it's
timed with the 40th anniversary this
obviously covers all errors of Star Wars
so you see bits here from the classic
trilogy you see bits from force awakens
from the end of that 30 year wait they
haven't said exactly which characters
are playable yet but Luke Skywalker and
kylo Ren were the big other characters
so this is all about the rise of the
first-order beginning at the destruction
of the second Death Star so let me know
what you guys think of this I do like
the idea of all this extra content
spanning all these eras is opposed to
the first game that came out it was a
little more simplistic and hopefully
they fix some of the people's complaints
about the microtransactions and crippled
versions of the game I think they get a
little better with each new release but
like I said it's coming out in November
right before last Jedi comes out they'll
be last Jedi DLC that they'll integrate
at the last minute and if you do want to
know some of the stuff that happened
during the rise of the first-order I did
that other battlefront 2 trailer video
where I explained in that I'll just add
a link to that at the end of this but
that mostly explains the aftermath
series and some of the big arcs about
how the first-order slinked away into
the Unknown Regions in what happened
before they came back and the rise of
Snoke so we don't know how big Snoke is
going to be during this battlefront
series but it seems like if he does get
involved it's going to be relatively
late in the main campaign mode just
because you start out with the
destruction of the second Death Star in
30 years is a big long campaign so it'll
be fun to see how they jump through time
as you jump through different stages of
the game but what's going to happen next
is is they did drop a rebel season 4
trailer it's the final season of rebels
it was a simple story
about a boy who was lost and a girl who
was broken
they fought alongside a survivor a war
veteran and a fallen Knight I led them
into battle against an evil so terrible
it tried to black out the stars we
fought for each other we fought for
those who could not but we never
imagined it would end like this
but there is going to be a new animated
series that they'll roll out that'll
probably be set during the sequel
trilogy they haven't announced a whole
lot about that but I'll explain when I
post that rebels video I'll try to get
that out later tonight but I've been
doing so many videos that if I don't get
it done in time that I'll just post it
early Sunday morning
so rebel season 4 trailer coming next
while you wait for that you can click
here for the last Jedi trailer and you
can click here for brand new Thor
Ragnarok thank you so much for watching
let's high five I'll see you guys in the
next video
you